all right I love that we kind of match a
little we kind of match like we called
each other I saw you back there and I
didn't see your pants I was like oh
cream you know I know it's nice I'm
feeling very earthy yeah how's your
how's your Smur going Summer's fantastic
right now we got time off got a little
time off we got a project coming up
later on in the summer which I'm really
excited about but in between times
spending time with the family yeah gonna
go to Germany love Germany where I'm
going to the Dusseldorf okay do you know
what so I'm going because my son is a
footballer I have to call it a
footballer because it's actually soccer
here like European European footballer
right I like the accent everything going
on yeah it's a character like that yeah
but he um very thespian thank you thank
you yeah actually no thank you he he's
going to this camp in Germany so he gets
to play like International competition
and stuff it's a big deal it's club
soccer things huge in Europe yeah what
an honor to get to play with him too
because it's just such a huge thing
culture it's massive way more so than
here which I grew up in soccer but no
one cared about soccer I grew up playing
soccer too but you play soccer until you
can play football like I played until I
played volleyball
so is there any other I know one of your
senses into European football but your
other son is into something really cool
like he really is he's gotten into
fencing as that's really cool and very
Posh it's very Posh and he'll come up
and he'll like attack me he'll be like
on guard and he'll do his whole foot
thing yeah yeah he does this whole thing
I said bro keep it up this will get us
into college like fencing yeah is one of
those Niche things that every college is
like those places they're looking for
and I'm like fancy schools stick with it
yeah and what a cool thing like to
randomly want to do fencing like I just
that was never even an option when I was
growing up like you know what I'm saying
neither was it for me but isn't it cool
you work your tail off though and your
kids get like this opportunity that like
we never have it's the best thing yeah
I'm gonna say like quick anecdote to see
your children pass you in anything is
always a great moment yeah my kids play
chess I play chess as well we're a fancy
ass family we try to be that bougie
black sort of thingamajig like we hold
down Scrabble I hold down some Scrabble
okay we'll rock some Connect Four like
we go accomplish but my kid my oldest
will like come close to beating me he
hasn't beaten me yet oh I love that you
don't let them win I don't understand
he gets that dub he knows he earned that
joint you know what I'm saying yeah yeah
but it's getting there oh that's gonna
be a really proud moment for you when he
kicks your butt and also like a tough
moment it should be both of them at the
same time I know I'm looking forward to
that for him personally
um so wait you just went back to St
Louis uh to give a commencement speech I
gave yeah you get nervous doing stuff
like that I mean you're an actress I
know you can maybe play a role if you
want to and not be nervous about it but
like that would terrify me it's the
writing of the speech that's the most
terrifying oh because you know what it's
like to graduate and be in that audience
and not give a Flying Fig Newton to what
anybody says I just want to go drink
what party am I going you know what I'm
saying I'm about to go kick it real hard
so try to come up with something that
sticks to people's ribs a little bit
that's all I'm hoping that I did
hopefully I accomplished that yeah
that's really cool thank you well I I
know that St Louis is big but Jon Hamm
Cedric the Entertainer Nelly like
there's some
there's so much you got a few folks in
the loop did you ever know any of them
like beforehand I know a lot of people
will know each other and then they we
know each other now so I had met Cedric
the Entertainer before because my wife's
Godfather was his financial planner
random right it's a small town so that's
how I know said okay and I knew him
before like I've any sort of Fame came
my way so he's a good good man good
person Jon Hamm went to like my
competing High School
right oh she met up in with like sports
but he's he's a little bit older than me
I'm not trying to put on blasters oh you
just did though I kind of liked it I
wasn't on purpose this don't crack but
he's a little bit older
than you a little bit older that's
amazing that's awesome so we hadn't met
him we'll get the text threat going soon
Nellie is from like the neighborhood
right next to my neighborhood in St
Louis too I've never met him but would
love to oh my God he super nice I met
him randomly uh very quickly I met all
three of them they're all like um such
gentlemen they're very cool dudes yeah
so we've mentioned your work with the
organization survivorship today so for
those who don't know can you explain
what it is uh survivorshiptoday.com is a
website hosted by bristolmeier Squibb
and it's about people surviving cancer I
got involved because my uncle passed
away from pancreatic cancer uh some time
ago but thankfully people are living
longer with cancer now than they were
when he passed away so it's a form where
people can share their stories of how
they got to and through survivorship and
it's such a big thing Carol because I
think when people get that diagnosis it
can be incredibly isolating and very
lonely and to know that there are people
out there that are and scary to have
gone through what you've gone through
and can share their stories at least you
have an instant sense of community and
you know that you're not going through
this by yourself so yeah that's what
it's there for going through anything
alone is
I mean I think that's the most
devastating thing about being a human if
you're yeah if you're expensing
something alone and feel isolated but
like I can't imagine getting news like
that and feeling alone not what to do it
may not think it's not this is not
cancer by any stretch but when the
pandemic first happened if you're in the
house by yourself like you have your
children we have I have my children and
my wife like I couldn't imagine just
being alone now sometimes I did dream of
that did you
perfect
okay so your new movie biosphere yes
okay so it's it's a different kind of
survival but I love anything survival
I'm into this stuff wholeheartedly but
without giving much away because I know
that you can't tell all of it yeah you
want to spoil it but they don't want to
spoil it tell everybody a little bit
about it biosphere so you're stuck
inside something with it there you go
that's it okay there's there's some sort
of unexplained nuclear fallout okay we
built something that we could survive
this nuclear fallout so it's just two
guys and we think we're the last two
people on Earth as far as we know
um it's heartfelt yeah there's comedic
elements to it I imagine there's sci-fi
elements obviously because it's a
unexplained sort of universe but there's
there's a really lovely payoff in the
end I wish I could tell you more watch
it though because I'm in it with Mark
duplass who's a great human being and we
have a wonderful time together I mean
here's the thing too though like it's
all about chemistry right of the people
you're working with so like what was
that thought like that you're like okay
so I'm gonna play this role with this
person that I don't know right and and
like if I if we don't like each other
this is going to be a not a fun shoot I
love when Texas comes out of Kelly like
it's so strong I love it makes me really
really happy it's gonna be a fun shoot
I'm just saying listen it's like it's
like listen how long will I be stuck
here here's the thing like it happens
all the time in acting like so many
times you'll get up you'll show up there
may be some sort of love scene in the
movie yeah and they'll be like all right
so first up is this love scene and
you're like I don't know her and she
don't know me like what am I doing this
the first thing I'm sweating and so as
it started I'm like hey how you doing
I'm Sterling taking off my clothes I'm
like if there's anything like that okay
I knew him a little bit longer than that
okay he and he's the kind of person that
is easy to know
um he's an open book he has two children
I have two children he has a wife who's
an actor I have a wife who's an actor so
we have points of commonality that we
can connect to really quickly yeah and
he's also the kind of person if you ask
him a question he's going to give you an
honest answer and I'm the same sort of
way so when people are open like that
you can build chemistry pretty quickly
yeah well if you had to be stuck I hate
to ask you this question because I know
you're going to ask me oh if you had to
be stuck in a room with just one person
and it wasn't your wife or kid wasn't my
wife a kid do my wife and kids exist
oh that's an important question because
I know where you're going because I want
to know is sex on the table
wait a minute if I'm in a room wait a
minute I just changed I just changed my
person of sex
I just I was like thinking survival and
then I'm like wait wait wait wait wait
there's another question no it's
anything is
it's humanity and it's fine it's um no
so let's yeah let's say they don't let's
say none of our families exist you just
stuck in a room and you have to choose
someone
all right well okay if sex isn't on the
table I'm gonna pick my best friend
Philip Grant who I've known since I was
five years old
that's awesome yeah since kindergarten
help you out like you know are there
survivalists he is okay he's like I'm
not a super handy guy okay but he is
like DIY all day long so he can fix
stuff okay so he's a good cook too you'd
pick him and he'd pick someone else no
because I can't tell him
yeah so that would be him if it was if
sex was on the table I'd pick somebody
else yeah me too
um
the table I
honestly think I'm I'm gonna pick my
sister because this is why we didn't
actually grow up together oh really yeah
we did it dysfunctional American family
um but um anyway but we're so similar
and I think I'd pick her just because I
think we're able to be very honest with
each other yes like look I need a minute
yeah without you in it
you know what I'm saying but also
all she's really we can both build fire
we can both do we're like survivalist
people really were you girl scout yes I
was a girl
yes I I love all of that I have every
book if you've ever came in my house
you'd probably be like she might have a
problem no but like I think it's fun
like I love biosity I'm I'm totally into
this kind of concept for a movie show
everything like so basically you tell me
if it happens I'm coming to your house I
tell all my friends because none of
those
prepared yeah
I'm like yeah I'm like everybody is
gonna come to my house so I gotta have
enough for everybody yeah um but yeah no
I'm that person who would want to be
stuck in a room because I'm I'm pretty
handy okay
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
I'm going
[Music]